das war nämlich gekochter känguru penis
herrlich ist bereit
jetzt hab ich auch gar keinen hunger hey
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es auch gut
gehen leute heute geht es um folgendes
ich habe diesen kommentar gelesen ich
bin denen hier einmal einen da hat
jemand geschrieben alex mach doch mal
das marie blind essen erraten muss ob
das gut oder nicht gut bewertet weil du
bist es ja in letzter zeit habe ich
öfter mal so restaurant test gemacht und
deswegen bin ich gerade richtig gut
dabei und können mich richtig gut aus
haben wir gedacht ich bestelle heute
essen für dich dass verschiedene werdet
also es kommt alles aus gegen welchen
restaurants bewertet sind im internet
mehr weiß ja und du musst dann erraten
wie gut dass bewertet ist hat das
einstellen oder fünf sterne weißt ja und
nach geschmack hat einfach aber ich
krieg einzelne sachen ausländer ist also
auch immer du kriegst ich hab gesagt
wann mein restaurant changes oder ja
klar also ich will eigentlich gar nicht
lange lagern ich würde euch erst mal
zeigen was ich alles bestellt habe und
dann fangen wir auch direkt schon an
wenn ihr sagt mach das bitte noch mal
umgekehrt dann geht man fette nach oben
ich will sagen bei 6006 oder und
schreibt auch weitere ideen wie immer in
die kommentare was geht also ich würde
sagen ganz schnell bestellen immer ein
paar sachen die marie denn welche raten
muss und ich will gar nicht viel aber
nur so dass ihr so einen kleinen
überblick hat ich suche erst mal nach
sowas mittelmäßiger das ganz gut woher
die mobilen fallenden menge ich nehme
einfach mal diese kinder box weil da ist
ziemlich viel drin mit apfelsaft ist
küssen und dazu einfach noch so einen
gemischten salat da kann man ja jetzt
nicht viel falsch machen oder tag kurz
bestellen reiche leute zur info das
restaurant hatte eine bewertung von drei
sternen also genau die mitte also die
erste bestellung haben war ich würde
sagen jetzt immer noch einen extrem
schlecht ist also möglichst ein stern
und eins mit fünf was hier sieht das gut
aus wir haben viereinhalb sterne sagen
das merkt man gerne spaghetti napoli
nachkommen wird schon passen und dazu
einfach nur pizza thunfisch die ist sie
nämlich eigentlich am liebsten ihr 4,5
sterne
das nehmen wir so zweite bestellung ist
auch eingegangen
jetzt brauchen wir noch etwas was eine
extrem schlechte bewertung abdecker
diese seite lieferando alte was eine
drag seite da liegt gar nichts das ist
so oft so dass genau diese seite von mir
nehmen und jetzt nehmen wir einfach mal
irgendwas was nicht mit pizza zu tun hat
würde ich sagen okay leute dass sie hat
zwei sterne ist das schlechteste ich
habe es nichts schlechteres gefunden ist
mexikanisch machos chili con carne
nachos de casa mexikanisch okay leute
jetzt bin ich ein bisschen ich weiß
nicht so ganz
hähnchen gyros mit 60 und zwiebeln das
will ich eigentlich nicht antun so was
zu essen ich sag mal so das restaurant
ist mit mexikanischen gegeben deswegen
nehmen wir auch einfach mal hier
die nachos de castro mit mund zu nehmen
wir einfach noch die hähnchenteile das
bestellte ich jetzt einfach mal dann
haben wir insgesamt glaube ich sieben
sachen und da bin ich mal gespannt ob
sie die die so eine zwei sterne
bewertung hat auch als schlecht
darstellt oder er schmeckt und die die
bessere werte sind das besser weil sie
nicht also muss man sich schon
angekommen auch eines von noch warten
aber du kannst ja schon was ja auch okay
warum ist das so
das ist ein fake louis vuitton politiker
muss ich die sachen blind erschmecken ja
was denkst du nicht hat sich dürfte die
wenigsten sagen darfst hey warum
was muss man mit eingebunden wurden man
muss jetzt mal silber kann ich das hier
abschneiden ja eigentlich schon so also
leute der pulli ist absolut nix wert ist
ein effekt stück und alex hat gerade
eine ruhige tripoli
so kriegen wir das hier doch passt
das tenniscenter lieferant zuerst das
ist am besten schnell ist muss er gleich
ins einfach zeit also ist kommen wir
jetzt als erste region und fahren ein
bisschen runter leute hier bin ich immer
die bewertung ein bisschen reggae okay
wir fangen an mit der ersten sache mag
ich die sachen ja die mag es nicht wenn
ich so viel das sieht doch gut aus
hertha ist so ok
[Musik]
machst du da kommt ja okay du also was
willst du sagen drei sterne hat das 3
sterne
das ist richtig ich habe dann müssten
kinder menü bestellt mit pommes und so
ich wollte dir sein ich komme kommt nein
ich hätte es doch jetzt erwarten ja aber
trotzdem muss das auch dass ihr habt ja
gesehen in diesem kindermenü da stand
auch mit pommes die pommes sind bis
heute nicht angekommen dass so ein süßes
baby pizza weil du gesagt es ist ein
kindermenü ist und wenn er noch kommen
ist glaube ich nicht dass krieg den
kindern der riesen pizza und thomas
schaaf leute die machen weiter mit dem
nächsten essen jetzt bin ich wirklich
mal gespannt
das sieht aber lecker aus ich zeige es
euch mal kurz in der kamera so sieht das
aus für einige habe ich einfach gar
keinen hunger aber egal
okay leute der nächste test mappus und
vielleicht schmeckt halt normal weil es
nicht so gut warte warte okay dann sag
nichts dann sagt noch nichts ich geb dir
noch das nächste dazu ist auch im
gleichen meister war okay das ist jetzt
vielleicht fair wenn ich das mache ja es
ist vom gleichen ressort okay obwohl
gibt auch erstmal eine einschätzung was
wir zu sagen doch jetzt soll nach
geschmack schlechter oder besser als das
vorher ja dann besser besser was wir zu
sagen die vier sterne also diese pizza
hier ist auch noch vom gleichen
restaurant okay
[Musik]
behindert was ist
hast du drückst du meine haare was mir
in meinem hast du wohl ich habe nicht
und was würde es jetzt sagen wenn du
weißt dass spies vom gleichen was wie es
etwas ist da die bewertung von im
ressort werde ich sagen vier sterne
das ist nochmal genau überdenken soll
ich dir sagen ja ich sag mal so nah dran
wir hatten viereinhalb das war das
allerbeste was ich gefunden habe aber
gut okay das war richtig gemacht
ich muss sagen dass jetzt bist du wer
wirklich eine granate was das angeht
also weil der einen sache frage ich mich
wo kannst es gern mal kurz einmal
umziehen
das hier war ein kindermenü dabei leute
die jetzt euch das mal ein hübsches
spinner ein joghurt karten sind unsere
schlimmen dingen so hatten
ich glaube aber die waren ja auch nach
wirklich sechs minuten waren schon ihren
vielleicht hatte der lieferant genau das
noch dabei und hat dann so als
entschuldigung
diese entschuldigung ja weil das
eigentlich war noch pommes bei leute wir
machen wir weiter
das hier haben wir noch im angebot wenn
es irgendwann klappt es mit fleisch isst
oder sondern ich hasse es
und noch ein weiteres restaurant
ich finde das sonst hast du gestellt
aber das reicht nicht so gut war dass
ich gar nicht nicht passt nicht erst ich
geb ich gebe dir nun ganz bisschen okay
dann gebe ich dir noch mehr kommen einer
noch jetzt wasser das ist schon offen
aus was ja okay das wieder einsatzbereit
also ich muss wirklich sagen auch vom
optisch markante zwei restaurants janne
was wird zudem sagen was machst du so
hätten es wird neben würde ich zwei
geben und ich denke das hat was jetzt 3
3 sterne also hier lasse eigentlich erst
richtig dann aber falsch wir haben zwei
sternen
also das war das schlechteste okay weil
eine sache kommt jetzt allerdings noch
ein absolutes highlight heute bist du
bereit
es ist jetzt zum abreißen okay die
einmal hier das lecker schmeckt ich
würde mich gut
andreas fuchs aus das war nämlich
gekochter känguru penis so was gibt man
lockt das warum chinesen ehrliche das
ist für uns nicht gemacht
es gibt ja auch genug der ja das ist
sogar richtig dass man zwei stürme also
ich muss sagen was wirklich an sich gut
gemacht das hat seinen cop ii kuck mal
das hast du alles probiert hier
besonders aufpassen hier die model kann
man doch auch essen oder nein ich bin ja
selber noch ein paar leute es war auf
jeden fall super eklig und ich finde es
richtig schlimm so sachen zu probieren
aber das nicht sehen zu können und
wollen auch noch wenn ich die anderen ja
und dann sagst auch noch so eklige
sachen also das hat so richtig wenn also
ich muss sagen wie hier kommen vom zwei
sterne restaurant also von der bewertung
her und ich habe noch nie solche chicken
wings gesehen die haben zusammengeklebt
heute das mit dem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen gibt noch nach oben dann
muss auch noch mal umgekehrt machen
können weil sein kannst du das für mich
machen musste und dann würde ich sagen
nein danke
wir sehen uns morgen ja checkt unsere
instagram kann ihnen ab bei mir auch vor
allem da kommen die zwölf was richtig
lustig ist bei mir auch leid das war
haut rein
jessie j